[Music]
greetings to my 3abn family and welcome
to another 3abn today Bible Q&A glad to
see you I'm Ricky Carter and I'll be
your host we've got another hour packed
program with your Bible questions you
know what we've got the answers right
here in the word of God of which our
panel is going to be sharing those
answers with us so let me introduce you
to them right now to my right I have
sister Shelly welcome sister it's
wonderful to be here please know that
these questions cannot be thoroughly
answered in the time allotted so we may
talk fast get out of pen and paper jot
down scripture references amen amen then
next to her in front of me Pastor John
deny welcome brother it's a blessing to
be here and uh some questions are
shorter than others and yes there is a
challenge trying to finish on time but
we're trying to get as many questions as
possible during this time so we thank
you for sending them please pray for us
amen amen and enjoy us got my brother
Pastor James rafy welcome
brother good to be here with you Ricky
and Shelly and Johnny Yes we won't be
able to get to all the questions
thoroughly but we do also have a 3ab BM
Bible anwers.com and you'll get a more
thorough answer at 3 AVM Bible
anwers.com so be sure and write that
down and you can do some followup amen
amen well before we get into the
questions why don't we start off with
the word of prayer Pastor densey could
you lead us with a word of prayer please
yes let's go to the Lord in prayer
prayer our wonderful and loving Heavenly
Father we thank you so much that there's
any moment of the day that we can come
and present ourselves before your throne
of grace and thank you that it is a
throne of grac amen and we ask for your
grace and your Holy Spirit now as we
participate in this program we pray that
you will give us words to speak words
that will inspire and words that will
bring life and encouragement to your
children we ask in the holy and blessed
name of Jesus amen amen amen amen well
before I ask the first question let me
remind you all at home how you can
participate you can do so one of three
ways the first way you can send us your
questions via email to Bible QA 3abn.org
3975 and then for those of you who are
on Instagram you can send us your
questions that way as well to at 3abn
official at 3abn official all right
Pastor James I got your first question
here when Jesus comes it says every eye
will see him even those who crucified
him then doesn't that make three
resurrections I'm confused please help
me understand that's from jeie in
Arizona who texted that to us
jeie thanks for your question from the
state of Arizona yes it is true uh the
Bible teaches that those who crucify
Jesus will see him when he returns the
second time now we know this from
Reading Revelation 1 and: 7 and also
reading Matthew 26 and: 64 let's take a
look at those verses uh in the Bible
First of all Revelation 1:7 says behold
he comes with clouds and every eye shall
see him and they also which Pierce him
and all kindreds of the Earth shall wail
because of him even so amen and now
Matthew 26:64 says and Jesus said unto
him speaking to the high priest at his
trial before his
crucifixion nevertheless I say unto you
Hereafter shall you see the son of man
sitting on the right hand of power and
coming in the Clouds Of Heaven so now
the question is doesn't that make it
three resurrections now Jesus says that
there are those who pierced him will see
him when he comes the second time at the
resurrection of the righteous so we're
not adding another Resurrection there
are just two resurrections the
resurrection of the righteous which
includes those that pierced him and the
resurrection of the wicked or lost which
also includes those who pierced him so
the Bible is clearly suggesting here
that those who pierced Christ will
experience two resurrections both the
resurrection of the righteous when
they're raised in what we could call a
special Resurrection only to be
destroyed by the brightness of his
coming along with the wicked who are
still alive in those last days and then
the special group will be raised in the
second resurrection of damn Nation after
the 10,000 years so in summary there are
only two resurrections that of the
righteous which is the first
resurrection and that of the wicked
which is the second Resurrection then
there's a special resurrection of a
group of people who experienced both
Resurrection because Christ told them
that those who pierced him would see him
again at his second coming and Daniel 12
and: 2 also alludes to this special
Resurrection when Michael stands up and
probation closes just before Christ's
second coming by using the phrase that
some will be resurrected to shame and to
contempt so just two resurrections I
hope this explanation helps to clear up
your question amen amen thank you very
much sir all right Pastor deny I have
your first
question is our name in The Book of Life
at the beginning of our life aren't we
born Sinners is the Lamb's Book of Life
a different book and that was texted to
us thank you very much and so let's go
ahead and go to Acts chapter 3 and verse
19 repent therefore and be converted
that your sins may be blotted out so
that times of refreshing may come from
the presence of the Lord I read this to
tell you that when you repent and give
yourself to the Lord that's when your
name is written in the Book of Life we
don't by birth by just coming into this
world our name is written in the book of
life this is done when we repent and
accept Jesus Christ as our personal
savior uh let's go to John chapter 3: 5
and 6 that adds uh some information to
help us with this Jesus answered most
assuredly I say to you unless one is
born of water and the spirit he cannot
enter the kingdom of God that which is
born of the flesh is flesh and that
which is born of the spirit is spirit so
this is describing the new birth unless
there's a new birth you cannot enter the
Kingdom of Heaven if you say that your
name is written in the Book of Life as
soon as you're born then you don't have
to be born again because your name is
already written there and only those
whose names are written in the Book of
Life are those that are saved let let's
go to Luke 13 verse 2 and 3 and Jesus
answered and said to them do you suppose
that these galileans were worse Sinners
than all other galileans because they
suffered such things I tell you no but
unless you repent you will all likewise
perish so repentance is a necessary step
for us to take for us to avoid to perish
that is is to die pay the wages of sin
let's take a look at the wages of sin
Romans chap 6: 23 for the wages of sin
is death but the gift of God is eternal
life in Christ Jesus our lord so the
idea that when you're born into the
world then your name is written in the
Book of Life does not really fit into
what the Bible says uh notice Luke 10
verse 20 nevertheless do not rejoice in
this
that the spirits are subject to you but
rather Rejoice because your names are
written in heaven Jesus is talking to
his disciples that were in the service
they were his followers and so he told
tells them Rejoice your name is written
in the book of life but the fact that
your name is written in the Book of Life
does not mean that it cannot be taken
out of there or erased from there and
this is why I read to you from
Revelation
3:5 he that overcomes the same shall be
clothed in white rment that is the
righteousness of Christ and I will not
blot out his name out of the book of
life but I will confess his name before
my father and before his angels so he
that overcomes gets the white reignment
and his name is not blotted out of the
book of life but what happens if you
don't overcome the obvious is true you
will not get the robe of righteousness
and your name will be blotted out I hope
that's will help to you amen thank you
very much
sir all right sister Shell here's your
first
question is the father higher ranked in
the Trinity than the Son and the Holy
Spirit but in Divinity one God that's
from luta in Kenya who emailed that to
us luta it's interesting question and I
think a lot of people have this question
on their mind the Bible describes in the
new test the
godhead as the deity and the nature of
God is the
godhead and it's three distinct persons
God the Father Son and Holy Spirit
that's not God the father plus God the
son plus God the holy spirit that would
be three Gods it's god father Son and
Holy Spirit one * 1 * 1 equals 1 these
three persons share the same
essential nature their qualities their
purpose their mission and here's the
thing they don't seek a rank of
superiority then when we look at how
they operate these three operate in
Divine humility in perfect Unity they're
not seeking Superior Authority all three
are active in Salvation one came to
Earth Earth and became the son of man
the Covenant Son of God and then one
became the father of his unique human
Covenant Son of God one is described as
the helper John 14 16- 17 Jesus says
I'll pray the father he'll send another
helper alos paracletos one who is just
like me not just similar but exactly
like me that he may abide with you
forever we see in Philippians
25-8 that Jesus existed in the form of
God yet he didn't think that that high
ranking was something that he to regard
the equality with God as something that
he had to grasp and hold on to but he
emptied himself of his glory he came to
Earth took on humanity and then he
humbled himself even further to die on
the cross for us he claimed equality in
John 10:30 he said I am the father are
one and then as the human Covenant son
he said my father is greater than I
that's in John
14:28 see in his Humanity Christ
voluntarily laid down and sub his own
independent Authority and submitted to
the father's will and he did everything
by the power of the Holy Spirit just as
you and I have to do amen so in John 17
verse5 he's praying to the father and he
says Lord glorify me with the glory I
had before I came to Earth and you know
I love what Paul says in 1 Corinthians
2:8 Paul says that the religious leaders
didn't recognize who Jesus was because
if they had they would not have
crucified the Lord Of Glory so here's
the thing about the three persons of the
godhead they rule in complete Unity as
the son of man it this is and with total
humility because as the son of man Jesus
did all things for the glory of the
father when the Holy Spirit comes he
does all things to glorify Jesus and
finish his work on Earth and then what
happens in the end the father is going
to subject All to Jesus he will his name
is exalted above every name every knee
will bow and every tongue confess that
he is Lord amen amen thank you very much
for that answer yes all right Pastor
James here's your second answer second
question what is the difference between
the 144 th000 and the number no man
could number that's from Carolyn in
Georgia who texted that to
us thank you Carolyn the difference is
that the 144,000 is a symbolic
representation of the saved and the
great multitude is a literal
representation of the saved now for
example God is not going to save just
144,000 literal Jewish male virgins who
have decided to follow Jesus in the last
days God is going to save a literal
great multitude that no man can number
amen so why the number 144,000 why call
them virgins why say they're from the 12
tribes well let's preface preface our
answer by stating that the identity of
the 144,000 is not a test issue there
are at least five interpretations of the
144,000 in the church today and three of
those five believe the number 144,000 is
symbolic now there are two clear
references in the Bible to the 144,000
Revelation 7 1-8 and Revelation 14 1-5
and there's another third inference in
Revelation 15 2-5 so there are several
characteristics of the 144,000 revealed
in these two direct Bible references
number one the 144,000 are sealed
they're the sealed of the 12 tribes of
Israel number two they are virgins not
defiled with women number three they are
first fruits who follow the lamb
wherever he goes and then number four
they have no God in their mouths they
stand faultless Before the Throne of God
so what do the symbols 12 tribes virgins
first fruit symbolize well according to
the Bible the 12 tribes represent those
in the Old Testament and in the New
Testament that are identified as God's
people God's people in the Old Testament
with the 12 tribes James says of the
Christian Church they are the 12 tribes
scattered AB raw James 1 1 and Genesis
49 they represent the born again pure
gospel experience that all the redeemed
must have if they are to be sealed
according to James 1:17 and 2
Corinthians 11: 2-5 and all believers
can only have this experience through
the righteousness of Christ that is
gifted to them by faith Old Testament
they look forward to that new testament
we look back to that but all believers
all Sav Believers Center their faith in
the cross of Calvary and the
righteousness of Jesus Christ so we
understand as Seventh Day Adventist that
this righteousness is gifted to all
believers throughout all time and that
no one not one single person including
Enoch or Daniel or Peter or Paul not
even the final generation of Believers
can stand Before the Throne of God
faultless unless they have the gift of
Christ's righteousness for all of sin
and come short of the glory of God so
the 10 144,000 are a symbolic
representation of the literal redeemed
who no man can count the symbolism is
important because it points to the
ceiling work the investigative judgment
character Perfections soldout experience
of Believers especially those Believers
in the final days of Earth's history who
follow Jesus wherever he leads them and
God counts all those who follow Jesus to
be in every generation to be part of the
144,000 by faith because God
sees those things which are not as
though they were and this is why the
final generation will in a sense
vindicate God by showing what every
generation would have become given the
opportunity that we have in these last
days with the accumul Treasures of Truth
to live up to by God's Amazing Grace and
you can look at Proverbs 4:18 and
Hebrews 11:39 and 40 and if you'd like
more details about this you can go to
our 3abn Bible anwers.com and there's a
a more thorough explanation there amen
well done thank you very much for that
sir all right Pastor densey here's your
second question do we know when Jesus
was born that's from Lords who came that
texted that to us from Connecticut
thank you very much uh yes this is a
good question but unfortunately we do
not have an we cannot give you an exact
date when Jesus Christ was born the
Bible does not provide sufficient
information to arrive at an exact date
and I believe God in his wisdom uh has
kept that specific date you know to say
December 25 was when he was born God has
kept that secret it's not December 25
how do we know that let's go to the book
of of Luke Chapter 2 uh beginning in
verse 8 now there were in the same
country Shepherds living out in the
fields keeping watch over their flock by
night they were living out there they
were uh abiding in the field and behold
an angel of the Lord stood before them
and the glory of the Lord Shone round
about them and they were greatly afraid
then the angel said to them do not be
afraid for behold I bring you good
tidings of great joy which will be to
all people for there is born to you this
day in the city of David a savior who is
Christ the lord and this will be the
sign to you you will find a babe wrapped
in swaden cloths lying in a Manger so
these Shepherds were abiding in the
field they were still there in the month
of December it is too cold they already
have left the fields they are not there
so it's not December the 25th and so
when was it uh it could be sometime the
Shepherds took their according to the
way Israel does their things with the
Shepherds they go out uh after the
spring and in the beginning of Summer
and they are there just until it gets
starts to get cold and they come and
return home so somewhere in that time
frame of Summer to almost the beginning
of November is when this could possibly
be but no exact date can be given to you
now if you're talking about um like a
year uh scholar look have looked at this
and based on some scriptures like for
example Luke
3:23 uh you can get an close to an
approximate year it says there in Luke
3:23 and Jesus himself began to be about
30 years of age being as was supposed
the son of Joseph which was the son of
heli and when you're reading in Luke
chapter 3 you see that this is the
around the time when Jesus was baptized
and if he was about 30 years then
based on uh uh the information there in
Luke chapter 3 it gives you uh some
details that you can say Well when was
this uh when was it that this took place
and so you can get an idea that uh
somewhere between 3 and 4 BC is when
Jesus Christ was born but no exact date
can be given what we should rejoice in
that he was born he is our savior he
died for us and we will rejoice when we
see him in the Clouds of glory amen amen
looking forward to that day all right
sister shelle I've got your second
question when was Satan given Authority
and Power by God before or after his
fall in Thursday's Sabbath school lesson
on November 28th
2024 condemnation it says the serpent
has eaten of the fruit and now has power
to speak please explain that was texted
to us
um as I see this God never gave the
serpent Authority or power over the
Earth he
created uh a perfect cherub with
intelligence he was perfect in all of
his ways and he had the exalted position
of being a covering cherub at the throne
we find his name is Lucifer and this
happened we see in his Ezekiel 28 1-15
it's explained he was unsatisfied with
his position though and he wanted the
worship that is due to God alone so he
we see this Isaiah
14:14 he let a rebellion in heaven and
he tried to usurp God's Authority
Revelation 12:7 and Revelation 129 says
that great Dragon was cast out and he's
called The Serpent
of old the devil and Satan who deceives
the whole world so he's cast out of s
Out of Heaven why was he called The
Serpent of old because he possessed
Satan possessed the serpent the serpent
had wings the serpent was a beautiful
creature it didn't it wasn't a snake
likee creature that we know today until
after it was cursed after the fall but
Satan possessed the serpent in the tree
and he deceived Eve he talked through
the serpent he deceived Eve but 1
Timothy 2:14 says he did not deceive
Adam Adam
deliberately handed over his authority
to Satan the Dominion and Authority that
God had given to the couple over the
Earth was
forfeited by them when they followed
Satan how do we know that this was
delivered to them because when Jesus was
in the wilderness in the New Testament
in Luke 4 5-7 we find that Satan comes
to Jesus he's being tested for 40 days
one of his Temptations it says the devil
came to him on a high mountain and he
showed him all of the kingdoms of the
world in a moment of time just kind of
like a flash reel of everything and he
here's what Satan said to him all this
Authority I will give you and their
glory for this has been delivered to me
and I give it to whomever I wish it was
delivered when Adam handed it over now
he says Satan says to Jesus if you
worship me it'll be yours but Christ
overcame that temptation as he did all
others as the last Adam he defeated
Satan on the cross Colossians 2:15 says
he disarmed principalities and Powers he
made a public spectacle of them
triumphing over them amen amen thank you
sister all right well Pastor James
before I give you your third question
let me remind our viewers at home how
you can participate you can do that in
one of three ways you can send us your
questions by email to Bible QA
3m. that's Bible QA 3m. or you can text
us to 618 228 3975 that's 618 228 3975
and then for those of you on Instagram
send us your questions that way at 3abn
official at 3abn official all right
Pastor James here's your third question
can you please explain Romans
14:14 this text is often used to justify
that we can eat any and everything what
does the Bible say that's from Bernard
and Jamaica who emailed that to
us great question Bernard thank you for
that question Romans 14 and ver14 says
and I know and am persuaded by the Lord
Jesus that there is nothing unclean of
itself but to him that esteemeth
anything to be unclean to him it is
unclean now verse 14 of Romans 14 may be
the most misunderstood verse in this
chapter and many people read this verse
like this I know and I'm persuaded by
the Lord Jesus that there is nothing
unclean
now there are a couple of important
points we should consider here number
one the word unclean mentioned twice in
the text is not the best translation in
fact the Greek word is common this then
does not refer to unclean food
designated by God as unfit for
consumption according to Leviticus 11
but rather it refers to food or persons
who have been temporarily made unclean
due to contamination with something like
a dead body or disease or an unclean
animal that's according to Leviticus 15
1-3 and acts 10:14 so in these
scriptures we see that there are two
types of uncleanness in the Bible one
describes the innate condition of being
or animals that God prohibits for food
because of their Perpetual condition and
also Fallen Angels who are also
described as unclean spirits Luke 9:42
but the second is the condition of
someone or something due to association
with something that temporarily
contaminates them now contact with
something dead or unclean like touching
an unclean food
contaminates the touch and making them
unclean for a period of time but not
permanently and you can see Leviticus
12:2 for that or also chapter 15 of Le
leviticus: 7-13 or numbers 19:16 so the
second uncleanness is referred to as
common in the New Testament acts 10:14
and acts 11:8 tell us that so another
key to understanding this verse is the
phrase of itself there is nothing
unclean of itself itself that means
there is nothing unclean by itself that
is without knowledge especially Bible
knowledge when it comes to eating
nothing is unclean of itself that's why
people in all parts of the world eat
anything they want including rats and
bugs and organs and even people at least
they used to because to them nothing is
unclean in and of itself so they'll lead
anything yet to the believer to him that
is esteems anything to be unclean to him
it is unclean and how does that believer
esteem something to be unclean well by
the knowledge by knowledge especially
Bible knowledge this Builds on the
earlier principle in verse 5 of Romans
14 it says one man esteems one day above
another another esteems every day alike
let every man be fully persuaded in his
own mind so those in the faith esteem
one day above another because they have
read they've researched they've come to
a place of conviction about it they come
to these convictions based on knowledge
without knowledge every day is the same
without knowledge nothing is unclean
without knowledge we have little
conception regarding sanitary practices
however with knowledge comes conviction
with knowledge comes decision with
knowledge we esteem some practices
better than other practices especially
if our knowledge comes from the Bible so
I hope this helps to answer your
question Bernard but if you'd like a
more extensive study on this a verse by
verse study on this chapter feel free to
email me here at 3abn james. rafy 3
abn.com and I can give you a more
detailed study on Romans chapter
14 amen thank you very much sir all
right Pastor deny here's your third
question what's the biblical definition
of mental
illness would you elaborate on the
meaning of being mentally ill some
religions believe being possessed by
Satan and feel that in the Bible when
Devils were cast out they were mentally
ill that was text to us thank you so
much uh I have not found a biblical
definition for being mentally ill I
don't know if uh sister Shelly or Pastor
James H have found one but there I
haven't found a biblical definition for
mentally ill this is a physical
condition and this is a complex question
because when you're talking about
demonic possession and mentally ill you
cannot come to the conclusion that
everyone that has some kind of mental
condition is demon possessed that's a
dangerous conclusion so let's take a
look at something that may be of help
for example there are diseases that have
similar symptoms uh for example you have
the common cold common cold what do you
get cough sore throat running nose fever
fatigue but I just describ some symptoms
that were very close to
covid-19 you you people had issues with
throat there was fever you can get fever
f with a cold so there may be some
similarities in the characteristics of
somebody that is demon possessed that
seems similar to somebody that is
mentally ill but we have to be careful
here we need to take these things to the
Lord in prayer ask for wisdom well what
about a person that is demon possessed
what what kind of
things um Can the person do to invite
demon possession that's where we can see
some things that can help us for example
if you're talking about a person that
was a Christian loved to study the Bible
and decided to step out into the world
and begin to live a worldly life but not
only that began to dabble in the occults
begin to uh visit witches and become
involved in
witchcraft uh do doing satanic things
well that person is inviting the devil
uh to possess him or her and they may
have have similar characteristics as the
ones described in the Bible then you can
say okay that person is demon-possessed
I'm going to read uh Mark chapter 9: 17-
21 let's take a look here then one of
the crowd answered and said teacher I
brought you my son who has a mute spirit
and whenever it seizes him it throws him
down he Foams at the mouth nashes his
teeth and becomes rigid I have seen
people with some mental conditions that
become rigid now so I spoke to your
disciples that they should cast it out
but they could not he answered him and
said oh faithless Generation generation
how long shall I be with you how long
shall I bear with you bring him to me
now notice what happens then they
brought him to him and when he saw him
immediately the spirit convulsed him
does that sound like some mentally ill
condition sometimes and he fell to the
ground and wallowed have you seen that
person with some yes that's also another
one foaming at the mouth so he asked uh
his father how long has this been
happening to him and he said from a
childhood now you can continue reading
the rest of the story and you will
notice that Jesus had to drive the
demons out so but when you talk about
mental conditions there is one in Mark
Matthew chapter 4 that helps us
understand that there's a separation
between the two let's take a look
Matthew 4 uh verses 23 and 24 and Jesus
went out about all Galilee teaching in
their Sy ogu preaching the gospel of the
kingdom and healing all kinds of
sickness and all kinds of disease among
the people then his Fame went throughout
all Syria and they brought brought to
him all sick people who were notice
Afflicted with various diseases and
torments those who were demon-possessed
epileptics oh wait a minute there's a
difference now and paralytics and he
healed them so the Bible does make a
difference here between somebody that
has epileptic SE seizures and somebody
that has uh that is demon possessed so
they they cannot you cannot say that a
person that has some mental condition is
demon possessed these things need to be
considered prayerfully and taken to the
Lord in prayer ask him for wisdom amen
amen thank you I would like to uh go
back and correct something because you
know I said that epilepsy is a mental
illness but it's really not it's more
like a neurological disorder and we
cannot classify it as that so uh I think
we need to take that into consideration
all right great thank you hey while
we're while we're making Corrections any
chance I could make a correction I just
realized I gave the wrong email the
email that I gave should be james.
raferty 3abn.org
james. RAF 3abn.org not.com but.org okay
great thank you th thank you all right
sister Shelly here's your third
question if you accepted Jesus Christ as
your savior and got baptized but lost
your way and stopped going to church
then realized your mistakes and decided
to return to church should you get
baptized again that's from George who
texted that to us George I appreciate
your heart so much I don't know how long
you were out I don't know to what degree
I will remind you of 1 John 1:9 that if
we confess our sins he's faithful and
just to forgive us our sins and cleanse
us of all unrighteousness but having
said that when we accept Christ as our
Savior and Lord we enter into a covenant
relationship and if we turn our back on
him and go out into the world and it's
it's like a divorce really so if if
you've done something for any length of
time publicly I I would recommend that
it's a good idea to be R re-baptized
that's a public confession
of your recommitment to Christ let's
talk about what baptism is in so many
people don't really understand what
baptism means in Romans 6
3-6 Paul says that when you're baptized
into Christ Jesus you're baptized into
his death therefore we were buried with
him the word bapo means to be immersed
it means that you're totally enveloped
in
you're buried in the water it's not
sprinkled or poured but he says in verse
four we were buried with him through
baptism into death that just as Christ
was raised from the dead by the glory of
the father we should also walk in
newness of life so baptism isn't saving
us baptism is something when God has
reconverted us uh or converted us what
happens is this is a public confession
we are bearing the past we are being
baptized into his death and his
resurrection we come up it's it
symbolizes we're bearing our old self he
nailed the old man to the cross and
we're bearing the past we're putting on
Christ's robe of righteousness three
reasons for B baptism if you didn't
understand why you were baptized some
people get baptized way too early and
they don't know or maybe you were
sprinkled as a child that's a reason for
rebaptism and then we see in Acts 19
1-5 that the Ephesian Believers had had
insufficient instruction they had been
baptized into John's baptism for the
repentance of sin and they didn't even
know about the Holy Spirit they didn't
know about being baptized into Christ
they were re-baptized and then the third
reason is if you have publicly denied
Christ
rebaptism is to restore the Covenant
relation it's a public confession of a
the Covenant relationship being restored
it's like repeating your vows amen thank
you Shel for that
answer all right Pastor James here's
your final question does Daniel chapter
10: 13 mean that for 21 days the Prince
of Persia caused God's intention to be
restricted that's from nathaly in West
Virginia who texted that to
us another qu qu great question here
Nathalie from West Virginia and one
that's really important to understand in
relation to the spiritual nature of the
conflict that's taking place on planet
Earth between the forces of good and the
forces of evil you know there are times
in the Bible when God's perfect will is
hindered or stalled or downright upended
by the forces of evil who are
influencing the people of this world and
especially its leaders uh let's look at
a few examples of that and then we'll go
to Daniel chap 10 2 Peter 3:9 it says
the Lord is not slack concerning his
promises son man count slackness but he
is longsuffering to us who not willing
that any should perish but that all
should come to repentance so God's will
according to this verse in second Peter
chapter 3 is that all men would be led
to repentance and saved and not perish
however we know from history from
experience from the Bible what the Bible
teaches that all men are not going to
come to repentance and all men are not
going to be saved and many are going to
perish why is it that God's will is
upended by us because we've been given
freedom of choice and we can actually
choose to to turn away from God's will
and do our own will and be lost Acts
chapter um uh 14 and 1 Thessalonians
chapter 2: 14 through 17 also talk about
uh Satan influencing men notice in verse
beginning with verse 14 it says for ye
Brethren became followers of the
churches of God and which uh which are
in Judea are in Christ Jesus for you
also have suffered like things of your
own countrymen even as we have of the
Jews who both killed the Lord Jesus
Christ and their own prophets and have
persecuted us and they do not please God
they're contrary to all men they
forbidden us to speak to the Gentiles
that they may be saved they fill up
their sins always and the Wrath has come
upon them to the uttermost but we
Brethren being taken from you for a
short time in presence but not in heart
endeavored the more abundantly to see
your face with great desire but notice
what he says in verse 18 wherefore we
would have come unto you even I Paul
once and again but Satan hindered us and
Satan hindered him from coming through
the Jews who were persecuting him and
made it impossible for him to go back to
this group of Believers and visit with
them and encourage them so Daniel 10 is
expounding upon the forces of evil and
the forces of good the prince of the
power of this world
Daniel is told in verse 12 the angel
come and say says to him fear not Daniel
for for the first day that you did set
your heart to understand and chasing
yourself before God thy words were heard
and I come for thy words but the prince
of the kingdom of Persia that is the
prince of this world Satan withstood me
one in 20 days but though Michael one of
the chief princes came to help me and I
remained there with the kings of Persia
to influence them to pass a decree that
was going to allow God's people to go
back and of course that decree began the
countdown to Messiah Jesus Christ
himself oh so Michael Jesus comes to
help put in place put in Action a decree
that would lead to his crucifixion it's
an amazing story that we see here in
other words all things work together for
good we pray for God's will to be done
we pray to be delivered from Evil and
all things work together for good Romans
8:28 to them who love God to them who
are the called according to his purpose
amen thank you sir thank you all right
Pastor deny here's your final
question where are the Fallen Angels
during the millennium are they with
Satan on the Earth are we going to judge
the Fallen Angels that's from Vicki in
Florida who texted that to us thank you
Vicki I would like to say for the sake
of those that uh the term Millennium is
a what is that it's a it's a period of
10,000 years that Christians have
decided to called that period of 10,000
years a millennium and that happens
begins when Jesus Christ returns to take
those that have accepted him as a
personal savior home to heaven for 1,000
years so uh the question is where are
the Fallen Angels during that time uh
well Jude chapter 1 there was only one
chapter so we we could literally say
Jude 6 but Jude 1:6 and the angels who
did not keep their proper domain but
left their own abod he has reserved in
Everlasting chains under Darkness for
the Judgment of the great day you may
also want to go to 2 Peter chapter 2:4
there's a similar expression there so
that's their condition now but during
the Millennium during the thousand years
we go to Revelation chapter 20 and this
is what uh we see beginning in verse one
then I saw an angel coming down from
heaven having the key to the bottomless
pit and a great chain in his hand he lay
hold he laid hold of the dragon that
Serpent of old who is the devil and
Satan and bound him for a thousand years
and he cast him into the bottomless pit
and shut him up and set a seal on him so
that he should deceive the Nations no
more till the thousand years were
finished but after these things he must
be released for a little
while the fallen angels are not
mentioned here the focus has been Satan
because he's the leader of the Fallen
Angels and the Fallen Angels the same
thing happens to them that happens to
the leader as the leader is mentioned
you you look at you look at uh wars in
the Old Testament they mentioned this
King defeated this King well they
defeated the whole nation but they're
just talking about the king in this
particular moment the same thing here
he's the representative of the Fallen
Angels when it says they are bound they
are Bound for 10,000 years the fallen
angels and Satan himself now this is a
chain of circumstances there's nobody
nobody to tempt because when Jesus
Christ returns all the wicked have uh
have been slain by the brightness of his
coming by his Holiness but but uh so
there's nobody to tempt and they are in
a chain of circumstances and therefore
for 10,000 years they have the
opportunity let's call it an opportunity
to stop and think and see the results of
all of the time they have been harassing
and tempting and they contemplate and
really suffer during that time uh for
10,000 years but the time comes no
change has taken place when Jesus when
they the holy city starts to descend uh
you can see in Revelation uh 20 they
they resume whatever wickedness they
were doing before and they tried to get
all of the wicked people together to try
to to defeat God and of course that is a
no no it doesn't
work God is Victorious along with the
Saints amen amen thank you sir thank you
all right sister Shelley I have your
final question in Numbers chapter 21
veres
8-9 God instructed Moses to make a
serpent and lift it on a pole why a
serpent okay isn't the snake a symbol of
sin I'm having trouble making the
connection could you please explain it
that's from Ruthie in Florida who texted
that to us ruy this is a great question
and I know that many people have gone
through the same questioning that you
are in Genesis 3 we see that Satan
possessed a serpent to tempt Eve and he
used the serpent as a medium so the
serpent has become a symbol of sin in
Revelation 12:9 Satan is called the
Great Dragon who was cast out the
serpent of old the devil and Satan now
let's look at the Israelites in the
wilderness and this is where this story
takes place they constantly complained
against God after he saved them he
rescued them he did Miracle after
miracle in numbers 14 27 and 28 this is
the Lord speaking and he says how long
shall I bear with this evil
generation who complain against me goes
on in verse 28 listen to this warning
say to them as I live says the Lord just
as you have spoken in my hearing so I
will do to you their words were almost
like a self-fulfilling prophecy so later
even after that warning in numbers 215
the people are continuing to complain
against the Lord and his miraculous
provision of the Mana they're saying
that they loathe the worth the worthless
bread they called it they're complaining
that they were brought into the
Wilderness to die what did God say as
you speak in my hearing so I'll do to
you so he sends serpents and they're
called fiery serpents because of the
fiery bite the inflammation many people
died and then in numbers 21:7 they
confess their sins against God and they
want to be released from this judgment
Moses intercedes for them and in verses
8 and N of numbers 21 God instructs
Moses to make this bronze Serpent and
put it on a pole the serpent represented
the sin just as the serpent it
represents Satan it was lifted up on a
pole and God instructed look and live so
when the israelit looked on that in
faith a serpent on a pole they lived
here's the deal this was a type of
calvary's cross we see in First Peter
2:24 Jesus bore our sins in his own body
on the tree so on the on the cross that
we might die to sin and live to
righteousness by his wounds we have been
seal uh healed Jesus told Nicodemus in
John 3: 14 and 15 just as Moses lifted
up the serpent on the pole in the
wilderness so must the son of man be
lifted up on the cross that whoever
believes in him should not perish but
have everlasting life so the serpent
represented sin nailed to the cross it
was a type of Calvary and just it it may
have looked strange to them to look at
the serpent and know they would live but
just if we have faith to be redeemed we
look at Jesus Christ on the cross know
our sins were nailed to the cross accept
his salvation by grace and righteousness
by faith and we will live amen amen
thank you for that answer shell well
we've got all those answers right here
from the word of God what a blessing you
know we we've got the word and we can
study it for ourselves and we're
encouraged to do so so we will know what
we believe you know if you have any
other questions I want to remind you any
other Bible questions you can find the
answers on our website 3abn Bible
anwers.com have you seen that website
you should check it out theyve got a lot
of questions on answers to questions on
who the Antichrist is questions on on
baptism on Heaven the judgment and so
much more you can find those answers
there at 3bn bible anwers.com so I
encourage you to check that site out
well we're going to take a short break
and let you know how you can participate
with 3abn today Bible Q&A so I want you
to don't go away because we're going to
be right back to have some more uh qu
answers and disc discussion with our
panelists and give them some final words
so don't go away we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at Bible qa3
a.tv that's Bible QA 3abn.org
[Music]
you know it amazes me the Eternal
humility of the Lord amazes me when you
think that one of the godhead came down
in the beginning was the word the word
was with God the Word was God and he
came down and took on our flesh so that
he could pay our be our substitute our
human substitute and take our sin
penalty God that that is humility to
think that God would take on our flesh
and he did it forever amen amen Pastor
deny uh yes I want to go back to Vicki's
question because there was another part
to it is and are we going to judge the
Fallen Angels well yes 1 Corinthians
chapter 6:3 know ye not that we shall
judge Angels how much more things that
pertain to this life so yes we will have
that privilege and unfortunately these
angels fell we have a choice to accept
Jesus Christ as our personal Savior and
we encourage everyone to do so amen amen
all right Pastor Jam some final
thoughts yeah I just want to go back to
that last question and just emphasize
that God's perfect will may not be
accomplished in all men as we noted in 2
Peter 3:9 but his perfect will will
prevail in those who place their trust
in him the Bible says very clearly that
all things work together for good to
those who love God to the called
according to his purpose so we know that
God is going to accomplish his perfect
will it's amazing to me that he would
allow
uh human beings uh to have that freedom
of choice in the first place and of
course that's what God has into this
great controversy when it's all over our
freedom of choice is going to be intact
and at the same time God is going to
have Harmon Harmony and love prevailing
in his Universe amen amen amen that's
good well thank you everyone for being
on this program and thank you for for
joining us you know I want to encourage
you to hide God's word in your heart
we're living in a day and age where
that's it's very important so I want to
leave you with this final scripture song
therefore whether you eat or drink or
whatever whatever you do do all to the
glory of God 1 Corinthians
10:31 therefore whether you eat or drink
or whatever whatever you do do all to
the glory of God 1 Corinthians
10:31 hi God's word in your heart until
next time God bless
[Music]
oh